5 26 on your wednesday morning you're
already tangled up drive on charleston
from maryland parkway over to eastern oh
it's about to get funkier scheduled to
start tomorrow night at 8 stays shut
until 8 sunday night city of las vegas
completely shutting down charleston at
fremont that's just east of eastern all
part of their long-term storm drain
improvement project that's why
charleston's got those tough lane
restrictions around maryland parkway
anyway here are the suggested detours
northbounders on fremont or boulder
highway you'll be called off way back at
mojave and go all the way up to stuart
for your westbound travel southbound
fremont drivers coming from the downtown
area you'll be coned off at eastern same
goes for eastbound charleston you'll
have to go south on eastern then in oaky
you can head over to fremont or boulder
highway now westbounders on charleston
you'll have to go north on mojave now if
you think this might affect you but it
sounds kind of like word salad check out
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy you can go over this all on
your own time hopefully work your way
through it buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone
the email address e traffic 8
8newsnow.com